c'est le jour j pour les championnats
d'europe qui débutent aujourd'hui tous
les athlètes se sont préparés pour
l'événement mais pas seulement
les commerces cinquantaine ont dû aussi
préparer l'arrivée des visiteurs et des
athlètes comme à l'hôtel ibis situé
juste à côté du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui a dû
adapter ses repas animé de la
restauration en tout cas des menus
adaptés à une clientèle sportive sur le
restaurant mexique l'heure ce qui est
située dans le même bâtiment que d'hôtel
donc des repas sportif de pâtes
blanc poulet de dinde en tout cas tout
pour garantir les meilleurs niveaux de
performance pendant cette édition du 19
jusqu'au 23 octobre l'hôtel est complet
ce qui représente environ 1200 chambres
mais il n'ya pas que les hôtels qui
attendent l'arrivée des sportifs les
restaurants aussi comme le bistrot du
théâtre à montigny le bretonneux qui est
prêt à les accueillir
nous on est un établissement qui
fonctionne relativement complet donc on
est on a toujours une deux ou trois
jours d'avant son stock et là évidemment
on a renforcé sur les produits notamment
les pâtes les choses comme ça qui fait
les sportifs prennent beaucoup quoi
durant les championnats d'europe le
bistrot du théâtre envisage une
augmentation de son chiffre d'affaires
de 15%
les championnats d'europe de cyclisme
sur piste se déroule du 19 au 23 octobre